[DIALING]
[PHONE RINGING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
(DISTORTED) This
is an intelligent
automated system.
How can I help you today?
IVAN RAMIREZ: I'd just like to
check the status of my order.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
(DISTORTED) Did
you say you wanted
to place an order?
IVAN RAMIREZ: No.
No.
I just want to check
the status of my order.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
(DISTORTED) OK.
I'll place your order.
How many units would you like?
IVAN RAMIREZ: No.
Cancel.
I want to check the
status of my order.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
(DISTORTED) OK.
1,000 units.
I'll place that order for you.
IVAN RAMIREZ: No.
Stop.
Ah!
All right.
Welcome to "Take5."
Don't you wish that building
intelligent useful chatbots
was easier?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: (DISTORTED)
Sounds to me like--
it sounds to me like you want
to talk more about Dialogflow.
IVAN RAMIREZ: That's right.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Do you
have a demo to show us?
IVAN RAMIREZ: Yeah.
Let's go ahead
and jump right in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Here we have the
Dialogflow console.
So let's go ahead and
create a new agent.
We'll go ahead and
call it Take5Demo.
We will select the
language, English, for now.
But you see we
have many options.
And we'll also
select the time zone.
Finally, we'll attach
this to a GCP project,
and we'll just hit
create a new one for now.
Now that our agent has been
created, let's go ahead
and define some intents.
But before we do, let's look
at some of our pre-made intents
that were created
automatically with our agent.
We have, first, our
fallback intent, and also
our welcome intent.
Let's dive a little deeper
into our fallback content.
This intent will catch anything
the bot does not understand
and respond accordingly.
Here there's no need to
add any training data.
But we can edit how the bot
will respond to our users.
And by default we have some
examples here on the screen.
Essentially, can you
repeat that again, or, hey,
I didn't catch that.
Let's go ahead and go
back to the main screen
and look at our
default welcome intent.
Here the bot is looking
for users' input,
such as hi, hello, hey there,
or any other type of greeting,
and will automatically
respond with its own greeting,
as you can see here.
To make things a little
interesting, let's go ahead
and edit the text
of the response,
and have the chatbot actually
ask for the user's name
as part of that greeting.
So here we'll go
ahead and add, what's
your name to every
single option.
Now, let's add some
common ingredients
that the user may enter,
such as hi, hello,
and a couple of other
examples as well.
This way the chatbot
knows exactly what
to expect before it
gives us its phrases.
Now, the great thing
about Dialogflow
is that you just need to
give it a few examples,
and then Dialogflow will go
ahead and extrapolate for you.
We recommend at least
using 10 examples,
so that Dialogflow can get
an idea of the kind of things
that you should expect
before it gives its phrases.
And once we've done this,
we'll go ahead and click Save.
Now, from an intent, we can
also add a follow up intent.
As you can see, we have a
bunch of default options
you could pick.
But for this example
we'll go ahead
and pick the custom option.
And now that we've
selected it, let's
go ahead and dive into it.
The first thing we're going
to do is edit the name.
And the name of this intent,
we'll just call it, saying hi.
Now, just like we
did before, we'll
go ahead and add some
training phrases.
Since at this point the
bot just asked us our name,
we'll go ahead and
give Dialogflow
different examples
of different ways
that someone may say their name.
As an example here, I'll
put just the first name.
And you'll see that
as I add examples,
Dialogflow will
automatically identify that I
put a first name, a last name.
And even when I add other
words, such as my name is,
or they call me, or
I go by, Dialogflow
will still be able to identify
which part of the sentence
is the name.
And we do this by using our
natural language processing.
If at any point Dialogflow does
not catch any particular name,
you can simply select
that word, and then
tell Dialogflow that that
is a name, that way you're
making sure that
Dialogflow is understanding
the context of the input that
the user is actually giving.
Now, as we scroll
to the bottom, we
can actually add the responses
that the bot will give.
And we'll have our bot
say hello, and thank you
for chatting with me.
But since we want this to be a
little bit more personalized,
we're actually going to
include the first name
input of the user that was
originally given to us.
And we do this simply by adding
a dollar sign, and then saying,
given name.
This will make sure that
whatever the given name
input was we're using for
our output from the chatbot.
And then we'll go
ahead and click Save.
So now that we've built
a pretty simple robot,
let's go ahead and
look at a quick demo.
We'll go ahead and go to
the integration section
where you see we can
integrate with a bunch
of different partners.
And we'll go ahead
and click on Web Demo.
And here we have
our chatbot live.
So we'll go ahead and say
hi to it really quickly.
And we're prompted
automatically to say our name.
And then we'll give
it a brand new name
that it's never seen before.
So here I'll put Enrique
Iglesias as an example.
And it automatically
captured my name,
and I was able to
say hi back to it,
even though it had never
seen that name before.
I know this is a really
simple demo of Dialogflow,
but just now imagine
the possibilities
making a decision tree
with different intents,
and different actions, prompting
uses for different inputs,
and then tying in
a back end that
can have actionable requests.
This is just the surface
of what Dialogflow can do.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
if you want to build
a great chatbot (DISTORTED)
instead of one of these,
you should be using Dialogflow.
IVAN RAMIREZ: Yup.
And in less than five minutes,
you can be up and running.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
(DISTORTED) Please
like, comment, and subscribe.
IVAN RAMIREZ: And if you're
working on any cool projects,
please click on the link below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]